we have multiple layers of craziness we
have the people who participate in the
systems and those systems have the
imprimature of social legitimacy through
the academy
uh
Portland State being my former employer
and then you have the kind of the foot
soldiers of the ideology and I think
that these individuals sheer certain
characteristics I wrote put a tweeter on
this and people lost their [ __ ] minds
can I swear on your podcast oh please
they lost their [ __ ] minds and it was
about poor body habitus of people who I
can't remember the exact quotation but
people who participate in certain World
Views I mean you see it with neo-nazis
right their ideology manifests and
everybody's just grossly overweight or
they're just like uber steroided
muscular people so you have a level of
people who have some kind of undiagnosed
low-level mental condition who believe
that they should be more successful
they're not they blame the system they
get together with other people who
believe this thing and then they go to
the academies or they even go to teacher
training programs it's like those who
can't do teach those who can't teach
teach gym Woody Allen's favorite thing
like they they they become teachers
and so we have a kind of
Western Civilization has seen itself in
Portland we don't need to go anywhere
we've seen ongoing continuous Riots of
people and we know who these people are
we know these people are basically
dyspeptic malcontents under accomplished
raging at the system they've told us
they can't be governed they put it on
signs right and right and and the the
offering of all of this and that's the
other thing that's infu not even if it
used to be inferiorating to me but now
it's just frustrating is the link
between the academy and the spell out to
the academy the link between what people
learn and how people get caught in the
orbit of the ideology even if they're
not true believers of every tenant or
every belief and then how that gives
cover for the radicals all right so here
here's the place where this gets strange
for me
I have
always been
pretty bold about
sharing my beliefs even if I knew that
they were out of phase with the room I
was in
right that's always been a positive
thing it's not always positive in the
moment right it does cause issues but
um but the net effect of it has been
positive
increasingly as the world has gone crazy
and embraced
sheer nonsense right in Portland here
most people if you ask them what they
believed would you know check lots and
lots of boxes that would cause you're in
my blood pressure to rise
but here's the funny thing when I
confess my doubts right if I'm having an
interaction and we're at the place in
the interaction where I'm supposed to
say the usual things about embracing
equity and yeah yeah you know gender
diversity or whatever it is that I'm
supposed to say I never say it and I
always say well actually
um I'm concerned that that is a very
wrong perspective and I explained
something of what I see I don't say very
much but I say enough that somebody can
register that I am not party to that set
of beliefs
I essentially never get challenged what
I get is relief from the person on the
other side and then yeah I'm not on
board with that either in fact and then
they pick up the ball and so I have the
sense that what's going on is you have a
lot of people who think everybody else
is believing this thing and they better
go along with it but the slightest
indication that they are in the presence
of somebody who can handle a different
perspective right and they want to talk
about it they're just itching to do so
so right so that's that's the culture of
pretending that I talked about and I
think it was breaking the spell then it
talks about the antenna talks about that
a little bit but we've created a culture
in which people are pretending
to know things they don't know and
pretending to believe things that they
couldn't possibly believe wouldn't
possibly right
men can become women just by saying so
enough that we should send them to a
women's prison even if they're they're
being sent forever they're intact so
shall we say right they're into heaven
had bottom capable of committing rape
right
um guilty of a sexual crime right we
should still take them at their trans
women or women period and no matter what
and his custom me in every conversation
I have to say this I'm sure this I don't
wait are we declaring pronouns no no I
support the right of anybody over 18 to
transition I support complete then to be
live fulfilling happy lives
et cetera et cetera et cetera this is
not about that yep no absolutely look if
you're really in a situation where
you're going to be happier and more
fulfilled saying you know what uh for
whatever reason my body is out of phase
with with my mind and I'm making this
transition I I actively support right
100 actively supported I don't support
pretending that that is more common than
it is and going after people too young
to have a nuanced enough mindset right
people who are frankly rightly feeling
out of place right if every young person
is feeling out of place because
civilization isn't working and then you
say Hey you know why you're feeling out
of place were you born in the wrong body
right right Abigail schroyer talks about
that irreversible damage it's the
clustering effect you see the clustering
effect and the point is it is creating
a artificial momentary sense of relief
that is going to be followed for most of
these folks with a lifetime of regret
right and that's the thing that's
so horrific about this once this
ideology falls into disrepute you'll
repute
who in their right mind were you going
to see epic gaslighting who literally
nobody is going to say you know when I
was in favor of mutilating the generals
of children experimentally yeah nobody
is going to say they're all going to
pretend they were on the other side yeah
you were on the other side all right I
never said that I never believed that
they'd be epic gaslighting but that gets
back to what we talked about before of
speaking openly speaking honestly and
like you said you know some people are
just not going to like you well [ __ ]
them you know I mean you yeah yeah it's
so also I wanna so that's it brings us
to something so if I said something
publicly or what have you that you
didn't like
you would and now I'm speaking for you
you would tell me yeah yeah and if you
said something well that that first of
all I would tell you privately you would
I would expect you to tell me privately
I wouldn't expect you to Productions you
know well it depends if you said
something that mattered publicly I would
feel entitled to respond publicly
because the point is you're having a
public discussion about something it
wouldn't be personal okay well wait a
second wait a second wouldn't it be
better for you to tell me privately and
then for me to perhaps reconsider or
readjust my beliefs publicly so that it
comes from me as opposed to the social
it depends it depends you know if you
say
um as many have that
religion is a mental disorder right as a
mind virus right which I think I have
said something very similar to that
wouldn't surprise me in light of the
fact that that was considered
sophisticated in new atheist circles I
don't see any reason that I shouldn't
say here's why that can't be right and
make an argument yeah okay so I guess it
depends on the claim I I guess it
depends on what the claim is
I I would think so if so let me put it
on myself so if you said something
that I thought was way out of line
I would tell you probably I don't think
it is way out of line to say religion is
a mental disorder I think it is
factually incorrect it's logically
untenable right so saying something so I
guess it depends on if that's the
question if I think if I think you
overstepped then yes I would say
privately look here's the problem I have
with what you said but if you're taking
an analytical position publicly I don't
see any reason I shouldn't analytically
point out why I know you may be right
and I may be wrong right and and that's
the critical thinking piece again I
would
wow how much how much more would you
respect me if I reflected on I thought
about and said you know what I had this
opinion Brad or whoever said something
to me I looked it up for myself I looked
up the best available arguments and
evidence from people on the other side
I don't have sufficient evidence I've
thought about it I've changed my mind
well there are two failure modes so I
see this as an important part of being
an honorable uh interlocker yeah
interlocutor
one people do respect you for reversing
your position on the basis of evidence
or a persuasive argument they it in fact
enhances your credibility with people
unless you do it too often because what
it indicates is that you're not putting
in the work on the front end trying to
be right so you're wrong a lot and you
reverse your position that makes you not
very credible so the ideal thing is to
do your homework on the front end try
not to make arguments that are
substantially Incorrect and when you do
make an argument that's substantially
incorrect or miss a piece of evidence or
misinterpret it get on the right side of
it do it forthrightly explained how you
made your error why you changed your
mind and then the point is that's about
the best you can do because you know
especially on complex topics nobody is
going to avoid being wrong all the time
so
isn't it better to have a friend like
that
who who has those disposes that's a
disposition yeah yeah isn't it better to
have to develop and cultivate a
friendship with someone who has those
dispositions than with someone who does
not I I would go further it's impossible
not to is that you don't want that as
much as you may in principle like
somebody who can't do that it's too
dangerous and too costly right the fact
is friendships are about something real
right friendships may be pleasant and
aesthetically nice when times are good
but the point is a real friend is
somebody who's there when times aren't
good and what you can't afford is
somebody who is going to talk themselves
into uh a nonsense position because it's
convenient to do so and a real friend is
also someone you know what they mean
when they're honest with you they're
forthright with you and they're telling
you something because it's they believe
even if they're incorrect that it's in
your interest to hear it right and if
you surround yourself by people who
don't do that
not only we ourselves writes about this
not only we will you never be fulfilled
in your life
you know those forms of friendship
you know virtue friendships
if you don't have that you're really
leading a life bereft of I mean you
might have meaning but bereft of any
potential that you could ultimately have
well I think actually the pandemic
revealed this in Spades yeah that
they're you know most people especially
young people who have somehow oddly
gotten over the idea that they're
supposed to partner with somebody right
who sort of see that as unnecessary or
Antiquated or something but people got
caught
without anybody whose opinion they could
actually trust and what they heard was
the party line coming from every person
you had no idea why anybody was saying
those things whether they really
believed whether they believed it deeply
so I think I think part of that
confusion comes from a whole consolation
of factors uh less so young people and
more so
um older people the older people I think
it's we older people just don't trust
our institutions anymore I've been
texting tweeting about this for years
now it's a crisis of legitimacy haramas
talks about it we don't trust our
institutions because our institutions
are not worth our trust younger people
often conflate platform size with
something to say just because someone
has a large platform in whatever I just
had a podcast with a really nice guy he
had a lot of
um Twitter subscribers first time I ever
talked to him
I really enjoyed our conversation
tremendously but just because someone
has a large platform that doesn't mean
anything nothing follows from that other
than if they have a large platform right
well you know I I think that there are
certain
rubrics you can use to figure out
um whose critique is worth paying
attention to and somebody who has
accomplished something
their critique means a lot more than
someone who hasn't or maybe even can't
accomplish something also somebody with
predictive power that second thing I'm
glad I I didn't interrupt you think
you're smart make a prediction make a
prediction make a prediction right
[Music]
oh